when a love child comes a knocking ditch
the Christmas stocking the first family
is not putting up Christmas stockings
for their grandchildren and pets this
year a decision that allows the bidens
to avoid having to hang one up for
Hunter Biden's illegitimate daughter
Navy Joan but in the spirit of the
holidays they will continue to decorate
the White House with random piles of
cocaine now that's what I call a white
Christmas screams
Hunter of course this marks the first
Christmas since President Biden publicly
acknowledged Navy as his seventh
grandchild for the first time back in
July you'll remember they didn't put one
up for her in 2021 or 2022 so they're
avoiding the problem all together this
time that way for Joe it's one less name
to
forget meantime little Navy Joan isn't
the only young person Joe's got a
problem with as a New York Times reports
many young Dems don't like them either
and this is the New York Times they're
usually so far up Joe's ask they can
taste his poly
grip but young voters are the likeliest
to say he's too old to be effective too
old to be effective try too old to put
on his own pants they're also upset
about how his handling of the his
handling of the Israeli Hamas War ju
suppose that with Trump's gains among
non non-white voters who
disproportionately are
young did I read that correctly yeah all
right yeah sounds right okay and it all
spells trouble for Old Joe no wonder
he's got buzzards circling
overhead see they have little heads of
Gavin
Newsome the buzzards
there you guys don't appreciate that as
much as I expected you would that took
three hours and a cost $10 million yeah
and because you didn't laugh I'm firing
the
artist for example a recent New York
Times poll uh shows that 62% of Voters
from the Battleground States who
supported Biden think the economies in
the crapper today while Joe's claiming
those Battleground states are essential
to the union defeating the rebel Army
after their Victory last week at bull
run but back to what really matters the
Christmas stockings yeah they'd rather
ruin Christmas for everybody if the only
alternative is to welcome a blameless
little girl into the family and
embarrass Grandpa Joe what's Joe got to
say no no no look look we were just we
always used to decorate for Christmas we
acknowledged all the kids all right we
had stockings for everybody we just
didn't put them up this year but we got
all the stockings uh we got Maisy right
and uh and who do we got uh Naomi right
and who else is here we got finnean all
right and then we got uh what's that
other one that girl uh oh yeah here we
go she's got the best one of all look at
this come on Navy Joan this thing's
going to be full of goodies Merry
Christmas every
everybody isn't this Charles like equity
in a nutshell if one person can what the
can't have what the rest have then
everyone will be punished across the
board I mean how much do they hate this
little girl what just this whole thing
has been a trip this whole thing has
been a trip why could you not just
simply if acknowledge there I mean and
then Hunter did you read he's like I
don't know I don't remember anything
like what it's a it took a DNA test
which shamed well I don't know if
they're shamed because you know listen
they never seem to express or feel any
guilt about anything but their treatment
of this little girl is horrendous it
really is Despicable uh I I just I just
don't get it hang up the stockings do
what you normally do during Christmas
because it's pretty transparent and I
don't why are they putting themselves so
far above this woman from Arkansas yeah
like who the are they that they're so
much Superior to anybody else yeah
really good point I love it when Charles
swears you don't see that on
fbn otherwise known as the
[Laughter]
business oh time for a
Rebrand so cat here's the deal here's
the deal this is like a personal family
issue and normally I don't care except
that the Dems make the personal
political right so if you're you know a
capitalist then morally you're greedy if
you decide that you vote for Trump then
you must be a Nazi so they make all
politics personal so this is then open
game does is that fair to say well I
think that regardless of that there is
the one thing that you mentioned that
young voters are concerned about which
is Biden's age and there's a lot of
things that can happen as time goes on
with every other issue whether it's the
granddaughter whether it's something to
do with Trump this and that as time goes
on a lot can change for the election the
one thing that's not going to change as
time goes on is Biden getting Less Old
yeah cuz that's not how time works yes
so I think that's a pretty big issue if
that's a people are that's the one thing
that's guaranteed to keep happening he's
not going to age in Reverse no that is
true but that would be fun like a
Benjamin Button President right little
baby by the eighth
year apparently you guys didn't see that
movie I don't think it'd be that much
different yeah it might not be much
different it's they use the same diapers
Tyrus terrible this is the opposite of
inclusivity
right this you I got to be honest Greg
I'm a little offended because you go to
me on a lot of topics you think I'm an
expert in yes and I think it's safe to
say that I am the leading expert on love
children
yes I have three of
them the same
year they're not I think you know I
don't know about the stock market but I
know about lovechild so I'm a little
offended that you left me
out and they're all my babies yeah what
I'm saying and so I I forget his age I
think you need to look at his heart and
his Integrity what man who's ever had
who's called himself father with any
type of dignity or Pride would cast out
one of his children like that's and his
grandchild I don't have grandchildren
but you know what I have I got six I
don't mind adding seven I'll put a
stocking up a little girl at my house we
got plenty of room she can come in I
mean this is ridiculous this is what
this to me says more about him than any
other policy I disagree about the fact
that here's a chance because guess what
there is more American families like
mine today than like your perfect little
facade or fantasy and we bring them all
in and all my kids hairs don't match and
I got all like I got to look around the
house and I you know I try to
decentralize as much whiteness as I
could in my household
but I couldn't have my set of youngans
if I didn't have one with a white you
know with a white mom so I had to bring
it in so I had one of everything so I do
I got it all cornered I got the Asian
Mexican black white I got them all I got
all the cars so anything new comes out
let me know but
uh Joe a lot of people don't know this
you have uh seven love children you son
of a
you get around I I am also
offended as as
Tyrus you know uh that's so fascinating
because it's free to be a grandparent
you know all you have to do is put up a
stocking that pretty easy no one's suing
the grandparents for grandparent child
support but it's crazy to me Greg that
uh Biden's not attracting younger voters
this go around because they have so much
in common yeah you know like they both
can't work a full
day they both can't live on their
own and it hasn't been all that long
since they pooped to their
pants well well done very good I just
like that line about it's it's free to
be a grandparent it's true there's no
there's no it's such an unforced error
yeah definitely all right up next stats
reveal a major drag nobody wants to
defend our flag hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else